hello everyone thanks for joining me
my name is mark keel and i'm the chief
science officer
and founder of genominon today i'd like
to present to you results from
our comprehensive amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis genomic landscape
and the implications for drug
development and discovery
the outline of my talk today is to begin
by introducing
als its disease presentation and
pathophysiology
with the discussion of the clinical and
laboratory diagnostics
and then a view into the current and
future landscape of treatments for als
followed by a discussion of what genomic
landscapes are
how they're produced and how they're
used and then we'll go into some detail
talking about the characteristics of the
als genomic landscape that phenomenon
has
developed focusing on some specific
genes
and their variants and calling out some
representative insights from that
landscape
and then i'll conclude with implications
and applications of this
new data so to begin
let me talk about the clinical features
of als
this is a rare disease with a prevalence
of about five total cases
per 100 000 individuals across many
different ethnicities
it is a progressive paralytic
neurological disorder characterized by
degeneration
of motor neurons in the central nervous
system
and the symptomatology includes
cognitive and behavioral impairment
and eventual respiratory compromise and
death
usually within three to ten years of
initial presentation
in terms of disease mechanisms als is
characterized by neuronal cell death and
dysfunction
that occurs through a variety of
different pathways
including altered protein homeostasis
neurotoxicity
mediated by rna deposition as well as
altered cytoskeletal dynamics
and other aspects of neuronal biology
usually culminating in neural
inflammation hyper excitability
glial dysfunction exonopathy oxidative
stress
etc in terms of the causes
of als there are two forms
sporadic which comprises 90 of cases
and is often attendant by presumed
environmental factors
and a less frequent but real familial
form
that comprises ten percent of cases
and there have been many genes that have
been implicated
each with their own unique functions in
both forms of als
and this was highlighted in a recent new
england journal of medicine review that
i'm i'm
showcasing here where you see on the
x-axis the year of discovery of each of
these genes
in the graph and as those genes
accumulate over time you see that graph
increment up
on the y-axis specifically the size of
each of those icons is a reflection of
the relative proportion of cases
that are marked by mutations in any one
of those genes
with the genes c9 or f72
and sod 1 causing the majority of these
familial cases
followed by a long tail of multiple
additional genes
as many as 25 or more
in terms of diagnosis als is
a complicated diagnosis with
a vast differential diagnosis of
additional
distinct neurological disorders some of
which i'm highlighting here
part of the challenge with understanding
als diagnosis involves a lack
of specific criteria
that can help differentiate from among
other neurological disorders
so those criteria that have been
established
are largely clinical and they are
comprising positive criteria as well as
negative criteria
for positive criteria patients must
exhibit both upper and
lower motor neuron degeneration and
evidence progression of disease
for negative criteria this involves a
rule out
of any one of those additional diseases
in the differential diagnosis for als
usually through somewhat invasive
laboratory testing including
electrophysical and pathological
laboratory findings but also includes
less invasive radiographic techniques
in addition to being a challenging
diagnosis
there are categories of diagnostic
certainty ranging from
definite all the way through to probable
possible and or suspected
part of the challenge here is this lack
of
objective laboratory biomarkers
the need for which is urgent for both
diagnostic
as well as prognostic purposes
and following on to the clinical
complexity and diagnostic challenge
associated with als
is the lack of effective current
therapeutic strategies
so these are not my words but to date
there have been
few if any commercial therapies that
offer a substantial clinical benefit
and most patients are are treated by
managing symptoms
and benefit greatly from timely
intervention to improve quality of life
and to forestall demise there have been
a number of
recently repurposed drugs applied to the
treatment of these als patients
but the most exciting recent
developments
in treating these patients involves
genomic therapies
that are targeted to some of those
specific genes
that i alluded to cause als
in particular as recently as
summer of 2020 two new england journal
of medicine studies won a case report
and won the results of a phase one and
two trial
have demonstrated that patients benefit
from
specific genetic targeting for patients
who have mutations in the sod 1 gene
this includes adeno-associated viruses
or aavs
facade 1 as well as an antisense therapy
called topherson
which is used to specifically target
someone
and so these advances are signaling a
new beginning for als therapeutics
in which some forms of disease may
become treatable for subgroups of
patients
with specific genomic features or
genotypes
that will obviously require sequencing
of these patients using a panel
or a whole exome platform or a whole
genome platform
and as thousands of these new sequences
become available
it's feasible to imagine that all of
that
data across all of those patients
when we better understand all of the
unique
gene variants that cause or are
associated with their diseases
not just for familial cases but as well
as sporadic cases
will open up new lines of inquiry
and a broader understanding of this
complex disease
to better inform novel therapeutics
in particular this is a review uh that
was published as recently as a month ago
in early 2021 there is a shift
in a one-size-fits-all
mode for clinical trials in als to more
of
a nuanced patient stratification
approach
with precision therapeutic application
but this will obviously require
detailed and carefully recorded
phenotypic and genotypic understanding
of each of these patients
to therefore guide trials and treatments
under the under the auspices of these
precision medicine
approaches
there's challenges associated with
applying a precision medicine model to
these
clinical trials i mentioned
the genetic complexity and clinical
heterogeneity of als
which is attended by an incomplete
understanding
of all of the disparate disease
mechanisms
that culminate in symptoms of als
and the the urgent need and a lack
of sensitive genetic biomarkers as well
as
the challenges associated with
accurately diagnosing als patients
relying as we do just on clinical
parameters
at present and rule out of other
diseases through laboratory techniques
and when in particular we're talking
about the future of als
diagnosis and treatment all of these
challenges
culminate in a sub-optimal clinical
design paradigm
which in the future will lead to
challenges to adequate treatment of
these patients
and so into this picture enters a
genomic landscape
and i'll go into a much greater depth
about what a genomic landscape is but
you can imagine
now a genomic landscape at the disease
level
is a thorough understanding of every
gene
associated with causation of that
disease and every one of its genetic
variants
and all of the idiosyncrasies and
nuanced associations
even down to the variant level for each
of these individual patients
a genomic landscape for that disease
would be a thorough
understanding of all of that complexity
and would benefit
researchers trial designers clinicians
and patients
by uncovering more targets allowing us
to identify more patients
and de-risk clinical trial outcomes in
addition
to allowing us to gain a more thorough
understanding of
all of the different disease mechanisms
and how they may converge
or diverge so specifically when we're
talking about a comprehensive genomic
landscape for als
that is to say there that comprises
every
als associated gene and each of their
genetic variants
that has ever been published all of
which
are interpreted after curation of every
relevant piece of clinical and or
functional information
usually patterned in the empirical
published literature
and that is exactly what genominon has
done for multiple genes
and multiple diseases over the past many
years
and the results of our work for als are
what i want to showcase today
the way that we produce these data sets
is through a unique
combinatorial approach that first
leverages artificial intelligence
to organize annotate and cue up
all of this evidence very
comprehensively
very sensitively across every paper
ever describing any als patient and then
following that organization of evidence
with an expert and expedited manual
review
that allows us to do this
comprehensively
and in very short order in this case in
a matter of a few months
just a little bit more detail about that
approach
especially in the context of
neurological disease
a genomic diagnosis for patients may be
a new territory for clinicians and trial
designers
it's not new territory for other
diseases particularly rare diseases
and in fact there are frameworks
codifying
the way that genetic or genomic
sequencing information
for a particular patient needs to be
interpreted
using that evidence to ensure the utmost
reliability of those
interpretations the what i'm showcasing
here
is built on the framework devised by the
american college of medical geneticists
and genomicists or acmg
guidelines and i'm illuminating here
just a little bit behind the scenes
about
genomics application of that set of
guidelines
relying as it does on a triad of
evidence
including the population frequency
the predictive models of pathogenicity
for each of these variants
based largely on evolutionary
conservation
but then the apex of that triangle is
all of the evidence in the published
literature
that usually uh speciates into clinical
information
patients cohorts and their association
with disease and their clinical
phenomenology
as well as the functional studies that
have tested those variants
in various in vitro and in vivo models
of
protein activity and so uh i'm i'm
clarifying here a little bit what that
acmg framework is
and i won't go into any detail about how
genomic has
semi-automated this entire process again
culminating in an expert manual review
of all of that evidence to ensure the
utmost
accuracy of the results so again we've
done this across every gene associated
with als
in the previous slide from the new
england journal of medicine review
now some years ago i think four years
ago say
which uh had an apex at about 25 or 26
genes understood to be associated with
als
since that time and and also resulting
from
our unique efforts there's about 10 more
genes that are known to be associated
with als at some penetrance
i'm listing many of them at the upper
right
but again when we produce this genomic
landscape
we look not just at the gene level but
also deep in detail at the variant level
and so across those 36 plus genes that
have been fully curated according to the
acmg
standards providing evidence and
annotations for all of the clinical
characteristics of those patients
as well as the pathogenic mechanisms of
the functional studies
all of that supported by the scientific
evidence
available to us and as i'll showcase in
a slide later
summarized for efficient reporting and
kept up to date
all of that work has culminated after
review of twenty one thousand variants
in seven thousand variants across these
three dozen genes that are associated
with als
including 1800 that meet the clinical
grade criteria
for ascribing that variant to
causing that patient's disease that's
referred to as pathogenic
or likely pathogenic by the acmg
criteria
so in a little bit more depth i
apologize for the busy slide
but this is a reflection of how
exhaustively annotated each of these
variants and their their associated
reference citations
uh is articulated in the als
genomic landscape you can see the
provisional
call according to those acmg criteria
after review of every one of the single
dozens
hundreds of articles that mention any
one of these variants
there's an annotation of all of the
clinical and functional features as you
can see there in the middle
on the left there's also
categorized and enumerated evidence
categories from the acmg criteria
in all of their associated rigorous uh
guidelines and rules and then there's
very detailed
and thoroughly annotated
explication of the clinical and
functional findings for each of those
cases
or functional studies
so i alluded to the overall yield of the
als associated genes
i'll highlight here as i mentioned
before that there's
a vast number of variants from among
those genes that are now
clinically associated with als based on
the evidence that we'd assembled and
reviewed
but there's also a very large number of
variants that were found in patients
and associated with disease but
for which there's yet insignificant
evidence
to to pass that clinical threshold but
which nevertheless and especially in
aggregate
are very relevant to better
understanding
some of the idiosyncrasies of the als
disease
so obviously we have all of this
information thoroughly annotated for
each of those individual genes as i'm
showcasing here
for one of the more prevalent genes
associated with familial als
which is sad one but to take you a
little bit deeper
into the nature of that evidence i want
to showcase
some of the findings for each of these
representative genes that i'll be
calling out on the next slides
so in particular at the upper uh
portion of this slide i want to draw
your attention to the fact that
the als genomic landscape produced by
genomic has uncovered three times more
variants
each of which is associated with a vast
body of evidence
compared to the number of variants for
sod one that are found in
clinvar which is a collection of user
submitted variants that are seen in
clinical practice
and when you look at the blue crescent
and the grey moon at the
right you can see how the the data that
genomic has produced in the als data set
is actually a superset
of those clinvar variants and in many
cases can reconcile discrepancies
or conflicts based on clinvar user
submissions
so three times more variants available
uh in the genomic landscape produced by
genomic than otherwise would be
available in clinvar
but then if you'll if you'll allow me to
draw your attention to the lower panel
you can see the linear axis of the sod
protein and its functional domain at the
bottom
but then in the in the two panels in
gray and blue for clinvar
and genomic i'm showcasing as each one
of those dots
a unique variant found in a paper or
hundreds of papers
and how they distribute across that
linear axis of the protein
and in this case how they influence the
functional domain of saad1
and so i'm i'm suggesting here that only
with a complete
genomic landscape will you be afforded
a view into the patterns that may emerge
and the
the unique activity of each of these
variants as they influence protein
functionality
just really quickly uh for tarp bp
there's four times more variance
in the genomic als landscape compared to
clinvar
and in particular if you look at the the
protein diagram at the bottom
there's a dearth of variance
represented in clinvar in multiple of
the functional domains in tar bp whereas
in the
the genomic landscape from genomic
there's
a significant number of variants
associated with patients
and often with functional studies that
can indicate
how that domain in that protein can be
mutated to cause disease
and then lastly for a less prevalent var
uh gene which is found to vary in als
patients
the tbk1 gene is
five times more represented in the
genomic als landscape compared to
clinvar
and again you see that the value of that
representation
in a more comprehensive landscape being
reflected in the patterns that you see
across the different domains of tbk
including the the tank domain there at
the right
there have been a number of genomic
associations associated with als in the
literature before
however they have been small in number
and the evidence supporting those
associations
has been meager nevertheless
the data that has been presented
does suggest that there may be genomic
associations with als as i'm
highlighting in this table from a recent
new england journal of medicine review
specifically i'm drawing your attention
to two such
purported genomic associations from each
from a single study
the first is a fuss variant the p525l
variant
which was found in a series of 11
patients
to suggest that patients with those
variant or pardon me that variant
present many years earlier and have a
shorter survival course
in addition to patients who have a
mutation in the sod one gene the a4v
mutation which were found to have a
shorter survival
as well in that single study so again
these hint at the idea that there's
value in better understanding a
comprehensive genomic landscape in als
to define what these clinical
associations may be
so armed with all of the data that
comprises the als genomic landscape
across those many tens of thousands of
references
and the the 36 genes and all of their
many thousands of genetic variants
we took a closer look at all of that
data
specifically focusing on each of those
clinical cases that were described
which in total number more than 2
000 individual patients and so
this is in contrast to the content in
the table that i showcased earlier
which was looking at single studies and
couldn't possibly have aggregated all of
that data
without uh an artificial intelligence
assisted platform such as i described
earlier
uh employed by genomic and so just to
orient you to the
the data that we were able to understand
here from our from our data set
this is now a distribution of the ages
of onset by decade of life
on the y-axis for each of those patients
on the x-axis out of the 2006 patients
and the distribution of those ages of
onset for all patients in our data set
with familial als
and what you can see here from the
histogram is a normal distribution
of those age ranges with a mean of 56
years for all patients
in our data but obviously we have all of
this data
precisely defined at both the gene and
the variant level
and so specifically when we're talking
about the distribution
for patients with saad1 mutations
what you see is an earlier age of onset
i think it's about a dozen years earlier
across the 609 patients in our data set
that had saad1 variants
there's an opposite trend toward an
earlier presentation of disease for
patients who have mutations in
the fuss gene as you can see here a mean
of 38 years
across those 190 patients in our data
set with fuss mutations
and so calling your attention back to
that table table one with the
the suggestion of genomic associations
particularly for fuss
p525l from that single case series
of 11 patients this
suggests not only is uh that there's
corroborating evidence to suggest the
idea that that fuss variant
is associated with an earlier age of
onset but
even more broadly any variant in the
fuss gene
based on this data you might interpret
to be associated with an earlier age of
onset
and perhaps a a worse
pace of progression for the patients
conferring a worse prognosis
and so um to our knowledge this is a
unique
assembly of of uh such a comprehensive
data set
to be able to understand these
associations
at scale again to leverage the quantity
and and
quality of that data to better
understand these patterns
that might reconcile some of the
clinical and functional heterogeneity
of als patients
in contrast the the tvk-1 gene which i i
spoke to on a subsequent slide
this has a more average
normal distribution with an age of onset
of 54 years across all 128 patients
who have tbk1 mutations i should mention
here
obviously tbk1 is associated with
other diseases in the spectrum of
neurological diseases
that has substantial overlap with als
specifically for tbk1 that's
frontotemporal dementia
is high on the list of the differential
diagnosis for patients with mutations in
tbk1
not only do we have information at the
gene level
but we also have more precise
information at the genetic variant level
which i'm showcasing here for sound one
so again just to orient you on the
x-axis is
the linear axis of the saad1 protein
with its functional domain
and then on the y-axis are those decades
of life for age of onset
and what i'm showcasing there in the
bubbles as a reflection of the number of
patients that we've identified
that have mutations at specific residues
or positions along the saad1 protein
and how those different residues
confer a different age of onset for
those
those patients and specifically i'd like
to draw your attention to
the the box in the middle there under
the residue at the 85 position
which is a reflection of the l 85 f or
v variant in saad1 which is
among the more prevalent variants in
saad1 which seems to have an earlier age
of onset
across the the many patients in our data
set with enough clinical information for
us to determine
that pattern in contrast to say patients
who have mutations
at a residue uh 1 14.
so we talked about age of onset and and
potential genomic associations let's
talk about
the rate of progression of disease so
again this is
the overall view for those patients with
sufficient
longitudinal information depicting the
the
rate of progression for their disease
and that's a smaller number than the
2006 that i alluded to earlier
again because it requires more
longitudinal understanding but that's
still a substantial number of patients
here numbering 587 and so what you see
here is the distribution of
speeds of progression for those patients
broken down in fast moderate and slow
demarcated by years 3 and 10 of
initial onset to demise and so
saad one for for whom we have 232
patients
that is uh relatively similar to the
overall distribution
of rate of progression for for patients
at large with familiar als
similarly the rate of progression is
exacerbated
in patients who have mutations and fuss
which you can see here as a
preponderance of those patients
with fuss out of the 87 have a very
rapid rate of progression of disease
so fuss is not just fast in its uh um
onset but as i showcased earlier um it
presents
in younger and younger patients which
collectively suggests that
variance and fuss confer a more
aggressive pattern of disease
so in contrast to the fast and early
presentation of als
for patients with mutations and fuss are
patients who have mutations in the vcp
gene
that are associated with neurological
disease including als
and what you can see here is that there
is a more indolent course
a slower rate of progression across
those 46 patients
who have als or who may have
inclusion body myositis which is the
common in the differential of als and
might suggest that there would be
benefit in more precise definition of
those patients
based on genotype of
genes associated with als to rule in or
rule out
different diseases in the differential
so just like i showcased for age of
onset for specific protein positions in
side one
this is a depiction now of that
distribution of
unique variants at different residues
along the linear axis of the protein on
the on the bottom there
as uh as compared to the rate of
progression of disease for each of those
patients and again the size of the
bubble
indicates the number of patients that
were identified in our data set
with those particular mutations so i'll
draw your attention in the upper left
that five that's actually a reflection
of the
a4 v variant that we alluded to earlier
that's an idiosyncrasy of the saad1
variant nomenclature but they are the
same variant
so you see that trend proved
out in our data as well in addition to
having been suggested by that
single study uh that was cited from a
couple years ago
so that lends credence to the
reliability of the other data that i'm
presenting here
most notably that variance at the 91st
position
in saad1 which overall is associated
with
a sort of uniform distribution
of rate of progression just like all
familial als patients
uh have in their distribution in in
contrast patients with a mutation at the
91st position in sod 1
have a slower course with a significant
number of patients demonstrating that
trend
and so again without going into any uh
biochemical details
this may suggest that different variants
in the saad1
protein confer different functional
effects and speaking of functional
effects
uh this is now a different gene the [ __ ]
bp gene
where for each of the patients where
there were
variants in the [ __ ] bp gene i'm
showcasing here
on the bottom there the number of
variants
which have a description of their
functional consequence based on
empirical studies
of in vivo or in vitro functional
studies for [ __ ] bp
and i've just listed the top 10 though
there are a number of different
functional consequences that were
annotated here to showcase uh the
the deep and and sensitive annotation
comprising the als genomic landscape
even among
uh empirical studies that may or may not
be associated with a clinical case
to better understand the disease
mechanisms that play here
across all genes that are associated
with als disease causation
so i lastly in terms of a description of
the data and the results of the als
genomic landscape i want to talk a
little bit to
the prevalence of gene mutations among
familial als patients
as reflected here and i think this is a
nature reviews uh review about als but
you can see here
for each gene on the um left you can see
on the right
their relative uh prevalence or the
proportion of cases for familial and
sporadic als
where mutations in each of those genes
have been found
and so for for various reasons that i
don't have time to go into detail here
um we're we're relegating c9 or f72
to a later talk but when you look at
saad1 and tar vp
fuss tbk1 and vcp genes that i've talked
about in other slides
you can see the relative proportion of
patients
uh based on uh some some
some small scale sequencing studies put
together to to try to
guesstimate what the prevalence is
and so uh that that allowed me to think
a little bit more about the the ability
of our
data in the als genomic landscape
to be applied in the service of better
predicting what the prevalence the
relative prevalence of gene mutations in
these different genes
is across all familial als patients
and so the reason that that came to my
mind is we've seen that
there's a correlation between the
reference citations for each of these
variants
and the prevalence of patients with
those variants
across disease cohorts and so this is a
different disease circumstance for a
different gene
in this case it's cancer and p53
mutations
but what you can see here in the plot of
article count for each of those variants
reflected by dots against patient count
in a representative and very large
cohort of disease patients
you can see on that log scale a nice
direct correlation between citation
count
and patient preference uh pardon me
prevalence
and so now turning our attention back to
the als data
across each of these different genes we
have a certain number of patients
out of those 2006 who had mutations in
any one of those specific genes and when
you you look at that data in aggregate
again
uh relegating the c9 or f72 patients for
a
separate analysis you can see here that
the prevalence
of mutations in familial als patients
that were projected from that review
hold true
based on uh an assessment of the
representation for each of those cases
with variants of specific genes
in the empirical evidence in the medical
literature such as has been aggregated
and annotated in the genomic landscape
and so um there's there's
much more detailed information available
about each of these cases
but to take a step back and look at the
value of this information
that we've aggregated i like to say that
the patients that are represented in the
body of
scientific literature and clinical
studies is actually
a reflection of the types of information
that one would find
in a large large-scale sequencing study
of new patients
and when i do some back of the envelope
calculations
the number of patients with mutations in
each one of these genes
is sufficient in our data set to reflect
what would only be available in a
sequencing study of
three to ten thousand familial als
patients
and so uh that's as i as i've suggested
throughout
a reflection of the unique value that
can only be uh extracted when you look
at this data
at scale in a very comprehensive and
exhaustive way
so i just want to summarize here by
walking through
again what we have learned which is to
say specifically that there's a great
deal of information available in the
empirical literature
that we've we've aggregated annotated
and analyzed here
uh for als across multiple different
genes and we've found
a number of putative genomic
associations
that have bearing on clinical
presentation and
quite likely and especially with
emerging genomic therapies on how we're
going to
better treat these als patients so the
implications of this data
um the possible implications that i
articulate here are that
there may very well be given the
clinical heterogeneity of als and the
diagnostic challenges attended with that
heterogeneity
there may very well be distinct
syndromes or sub syndromes
that could be better predicted with a
more comprehensive understanding of
genotypes for all of these als patients
either to speciate different patients
with als
defined by those clinical parameters or
otherwise
to better understand which patients have
als
or some other disease in the
differential diagnosis
similarly having this understanding from
this data
allows one to better understand all of
the idiosyncratic
disease mechanisms across all of these
different genes and how those disease
mechanisms
at the biochemical level may be
influencing the clinical features that
we
alluded to in those trends that i
highlighted
the possible applications of this data
in the als genomic landscape are in
resolving that diagnostic uncertainty
that i spoke to earlier
which would be a sea change in the way
that neurology patients in general and
als patients specifically
are currently diagnosed as well as as
was suggested before about the change
from a one size fits all clinical trial
model
to a more personalized medicine approach
using the als data set
that i've discussed here will allow
clinical trial designers to better
segregate patients a priori by genotype
to ensure a more likely successful
outcome of those trials
meeting the endpoints especially as the
therapies are predicated on
specific disease pathology or specific
just
gene mutations in those patients and
then finally forward looking
when when all of this trial data
has been accumulated i foresee that
having a better understanding of the
genomic
underpinnings of als disease causation
will
much more precisely
allow us to dictate which patients
should get which treatments so that we
can ensure improved outcomes
for all patients regardless of their
unique genomic makeup
so in conclusion here i'd like to just
state that janomenon
produces these landscapes across all
different diseases
and specifically what i'd like to
highlight here is that we've we've done
such a an exhaustive analysis as i've
showcased here for als
for other neurodegenerative diseases
including parkinson's disease
with i think more than four dozen five
dozen
genes associated with parkinson's
disease and parkinsonism or parkinson's
disease risk
all exhaustively annotated in in the
ways that i described for als
we're we're making great progress on
alzheimer's disease as well a number of
genes associated
or presumed to be associated with
alzheimer's are are being analyzed in
this way
uh as i described for als and so too for
wilson's disease
and so altogether the promulgation of
this data
across all of neurodegenerative disease
i think will reveal unprecedented
insight
into the disease mechanisms of these
different disease entities
as well as as i showcased the the unique
clinical presentations
that may be speciated by these genomic
findings and how that has bearing on how
we
test and treat patients in clinical
trials
and moving on into clinical practice in
the future
so with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention and encourage anyone of
you who's interested in learning more to
reach out to me at the email below